I'll talk about this triptych okay I
just have to say on my favorite I love
this three-part birth of a louse I mean
I love the fact that there's a narrative
to the piece but this guy Barrett's who
made this this picture was one of the
earliest photographers to try and apply
photography you know to the microscope
what's amazing is the technical
challenges that he had to overcome to
make these pictures you don't see it
because they're so extraordinarily
accomplished we developed both his own
apparatus for coupling the camera in the
microscope and he improved the chemistry
of the photographic negative to better
adapt it for this purpose so what you
really didn't build this body of
pictures that show off what photography
could bring to microscopy we prior to
the 19th century the scientific
illustration tend to represent a type an
ideal so if you were gonna you know do a
picture of a flower for example the
illustrator would look at 20 flowers and
then take the common features and make
an ideal flower but a photograph always
represents one particular flower so if
that particular one happens to have a
defective petal or something peculiar to
it you never really know does that
photograph substitute then for you know
that type of flower in general or is it
only represent that one specimen so
photography wasn't immediately accepted
as a substitute for drawing for that
reason really he really struggled to to
address any sort of challenge that
scientists could say well photography
can't do this he tried to address that
and so we made this incredible portfolio
of images that he gave to the minister
of Education and information as a way of
demonstrating with photography could do